what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the fall of X and the
Juggernaut stops holding back so as
always there will be a link to the
follow ofex playlist at the end of this
video in case you need to get caught up
but what this does here before we get to
the Juggernaut segment what it does here
is it picks up with Sunfire now I know
it doesn't seem to be overly important
this part is dope and the reason why is
because this initially picks up with a
mission that Sunfire was sent on now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with this character Sunfire is like the
X-Men version of Johnny Storm from the
Fantastic 4 he can set himself on fire
he can get as hot as the sun he has his
own history and all that kind of stuff
right but he's really really cool and
he's incredibly powerful but this
Mission he was on took place before kcoa
fell to the forces of orcus so he
doesn't know everything that's happened
over the course of fall of X so far he's
just been out there doing his own thing
and so so what ends up happening is he
was sent on this mission to basically
grab what was called red root the forest
now if you're not familiar with redroot
the forest it's not overly important
here it's just one of those things where
redroot is part of the mutant population
a relatively important character but the
reality here is that red root was needed
for what will likely be a plot device
over the course of this story at some
point in time the kicker about all this
is that Sunfire grabs red root puts it
close to his chest and then it allows
redroot to kind of stay warm travel so
on and so forth but when he gets to kind
of the destination which is to say where
he's going to be traveling to for the
next leg of his journey what he does is
he comes across this being or this
mutant that he had basically paid to
give him the location to take him where
he was supposed to be when he crawls
through like this giant mouth
effectively right it's just one of these
weird things he passes into What's
called the void right meaning he goes
into this place where he has no clue
where he's at we don't even fully know
where he's at but because the journey is
so harsh and God this is so ridiculously
dope because the journey is so harsh he
ultimately collapses but then he's met
by this colossal figure and the thing he
says here right the thing that Sunfire
says is he says I have failed you my
Iraqi sister this is the end of all
things and this person responds what is
an end my child if not a beginning the
last seed of okara needs but one thing
to grow mutant blood and Sunfire
recognizes this person now the whole
thing with okara and arachi and all that
kind of stuff we can kind of ignore that
for right now because what this person
says is the magic has led you to my side
once more and he says be healed Sunfire
and be prepared for we will march to war
it's apocalypse right now the last we
saw with apocalypse he had left to this
other dimension and basically come back
to earth or at least to the main Marvel
Universe and he's just been been
traveling around what it looks like he's
doing here is he's going to turn Sunfire
into one of his Horsemen and for anybody
out there who knows anything about
apocalypse and his Horsemen you guys
know when that happens your powers get
augmented and you usually become vastly
more powerful Sunfire as a Herald of
Apocalypse between these two could take
all comers right there's no reason to
believe they couldn't take down orcus by
themselves so the question has to be
asked what happens when he builds his
army up now for the Juggernaut portion
the reason you guys clicked on this
video so what this does is this
basically picks up at the main orcus
facility itself again for those of you
guys getting caught up orcus is an
organization that's been attacking all
the mutants and basically wiped out kcoa
the home of the mutant population and so
on and so forth and what we get here is
a conversation between Dr stasis firar
and Fa long now a little bit of catch up
here for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with everything going on Dr
stasis is is basically a clone of the
original Nathaniel Essex Mr Sinister
that guy's long since been dead and all
the versions of sinister really the main
version with a diamond on his head that
we've seen all this time was a clone
right it wasn't until recently that we
learned there were three others right Dr
stasis orbit Solaris and then mother
righteous the female clone of Mr
Sinister but in essence Dr stasis is
kind of like the mutant and I I say that
in quotation marks who's kind of like
helping orcus take down other mutants F
long is a guy who who effectively took
over Stark Industries so he's got all
the access to Tony Stark's technology
and firar is a mutant who's actually on
the side of the ex-men but Gan gray of
the X-Men before she died put a
telepathic thought in the mind of Dr
stasis tricking him into believing firar
has been working with them the entire
time so she's basically a spy but one of
the things they talk about is what had
recently happened with Juggernaut but
for those of you guys who aren't really
caught up and again you'll find all this
information in the fall of X playlist
Kitty Pride of the X-Men had snuck
aboard and then enabled the
circumstances whereby Juggernaut could
get free he escaped but then Nimrod beat
the crap out of him right beat the
absolute tar out of him and so in turn
what Firestar is doing is she's
basically kind of maintaining her role
where she's assigned to go to Cyclops
who's currently being held by orcus and
basically tell him take the plea deal
that orcus is offering you in effect
turn against the mutant population right
walk out there in the general public and
say that the mutant population are the
bad guys they're the villains here that
orcus was right in their decision to
attack the mutant population and that
the mutants brought this on themselves
of course it's all a gigantic lie none
of it is true but that's the role that
she's assigned to play here and so what
she does is she actually moves past the
juggernaut's room which of course this
guy is currently in stasis because the
juggernaut's just been absolutely
pummeled by Nimrod that just kind of
gives you guys perspective on how
powerful Nimrod The Sentinel is right
that guy is on a whole another level but
what what firar does is she kind of like
sneaks through right she starts moving
through and in fact she actually goes
into the room of the Juggernaut himself
and then enables a circumstance that
allows him to escape yet again then she
goes into the room of Cyclops who again
is being held captive by orcus and she
does exactly what she was told to do
right she says look at you Cyclops
actually I guess introspection was never
your thing especially now of course he
calls her a traitor and her response is
you're making what's left of your life a
living hell right it's one of these
things where she's playing the role and
she has to right she has to look like
the bad guy here she can't sneakily tell
Cyclops actually I'm the good guy right
I'm here on your side Gan gray put a
telepathic thought in the mind of Dr
stasis and tricked him into thinking
that I've been working with him the
whole time but I'm really on your side
I'm just biting my time and eventually
we'll free you she can't say that right
because who knows what ears are
listening so she plays her part the way
that she's supposed to even convincing
py clops that she is a straight up
villain here that she turned against the
mutant population but in the midst of
this whole discussion there's this
gigantic Rumble and then Juggernaut
emerges now this is why I say this is
where Juggernaut stops holding back and
the reason why is because this version
of Juggernaut is very reminiscent of the
old version of Kan Marco the one from
eons ago that guy didn't care man like
Kan Marco from like back in the 80s that
guy did not care if you were a person
that he was fighting and other people
died as collateral damage hey man that's
how you go you should have been
somewhere else that was his stance right
that's how he saw things but in more
recent years Juggernaut has basically
turned over a new leaf and become a hero
this is him reverting back to the old
ways because he says I was about to
check out of this goog but now that the
traitor here I might stick around and
have some fun and he's like they're
going to kill you when they're done with
with you right like consider what I'm
about to do to you mercy and firear
literally like blasts his foot but then
you have like these soldiers who kind of
show up here Juggernaut like kills them
all like that doesn't even think about
it right takes these guys out in one
Fell Swoop grabs firar and then in turn
she's like honestly I'm okay with that
now eat this and then she gives him the
like a thumb drive and of course
following that Juggernaut literally
smashes through the facility and
ultimately escapes right at this he
meets up with the remainder of the X-Men
right the remainder of those individuals
who were still on Earth lur Kenny x23
sink Miss Marvel and kitty Pride now the
thing here is that in this conversation
it's an awesome idea because what goes
on is the information given to
Juggernaut was actually how to
deactivate the bomb that was under
Cyclops that's one of the questions a
lot of you guys had in the previous
instance that we covered of X-Men which
was that kitty Pride couldn't simply
just freey cops because if she did it
would activate the bomb that was tied to
Juggernaut a lot of the guys were asking
like why doesn't she just phase him
through or something like that it's most
likely a pressure switch that's tied to
the weight of his body right so if the
weight changes in any way boom like
Juggernaut dies and it would have been a
foolish maneuver to do because
Juggernaut despite the fact that this
guy is clearly not the sharpest tool in
the shed he's a guy you want on your
side Juggernaut is a guy that you want
in your corner when things pop off and
so trying to preserve the life of
Juggernaut and the life of Cyclops was
no easy task I figured we'd kind of nip
that in the bud in this video as opposed
to doing it in like a different video
and so what ends up going on is they say
okay cool this gives us the ability to
effectively free Cyclops the question is
how do we do it right because they say
orcus detected a group of mutants who
registered the push into the gates of
Xavier right when Xavier forced all the
mutants to leave Earth under the
direction of orcus they all ended up
basically outside of all space and time
which is kind of a crazy situation but
the question of Miss Marvel is where are
we going she's probably asking that
question so she can do the same thing
she's been doing which is nothing but
one of the things that happens is that
you have this kind of discussion between
Firestar Nimrod as well as everybody
else here they're all basically grilling
her right because in their mind they
don't really trust Firestar now because
the telepathic thought is in the mind of
Dr stasis he trusts her implicitly
because he doesn't know that he's been
telepathically tricked and as far as
everybody else is concerned they follow
the direction of Dr stasis right they do
what he tells them to do anything other
than that and they put their own lives
at risk but under the radar they don't
see her as an ally and even if they did
at the end of the day she's a mutant
right they see their alliance with her
as something that's temporary when the
time comes when all mutants got to go
that includes her of course nimrod is
watching all this unfold I'm still
excited to see what they do with Nimrod
and like this grand scheme but one of
the things that kind of happens is that
as firar plays her part she challenges
them exactly the way that you would
expect her to right if you're going to
pull a dagger on me at least use it
right if not then get out of my face
with it I'm going to go take a whole
bunch of pain pills so I can basically
get over all this these injuries that
I'm sustaining and just go figure out
what my next move is going to be or
await my orders but their stance here is
this girl's outweighed her usefulness
right like she's out her usefulness it's
time for her to go and so what we end up
doing and this is a crazy ending what we
end up doing here is switching over to
Kitty pride and Miss Marvel who have
gone on this Mission now Kitty Pride
makes the most sense just because of the
fact that she's like the deadliest X-Men
in Marvel Comics right now right I mean
like kitty Pride as an assassin is
probably the greatest thing I never knew
I needed in the X-Men Comics it's dope
but they end up meeting with Wolverine
because with Miss Marvel being here I
assume she's here either as a training
Mission or so that Marvel Comics can
expose us to her as often as they can
among the X-Men so we get used to it I
don't know I have no idea what their
intention is but the kicker here is that
as they're talking right her statement
the statement of Miss Marvel is maybe we
should talk later right let's go find
our mutant friends where is this Germany
Austria and the response of wolver rain
is you didn't tell her right like that's
literally the question he ask Kitty
pride and her statement is I didn't even
want her here but our dear leaders
insisted and so the response of Miss
Marvel is you know I find it hard to
believe you were ever a teacher right
like you hate kids like do you hate kids
or do you just hate me and she's like am
I way off right is this like Austria or
Switzerland now here's the thing about
this they are in a place right the
reason why they're here is because there
are five mutant signals that have been
registered on Earth in a safe haven that
not even orcus will go to orcus will not
go to this location and the reason for
that is because to do so is a Fool's
errand why is it a Fool's errand you say
why would it be foolish to go to this
location because my dear friends as the
three of them are talking a voice chimes
in and says some good news child we're
not in Europe at all this is Latveria
that's right ladies and gentlemen Dr
Doom has officially entered the fall of
x and I know you guys love Dr Doom with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end as always
make sure you click this link to the
playlist in order to get caught up and I
will catch you all later peace